good, let's go to your top five
takeaways from yesterday. And
I want to start with Antonio
Brown and that Antonio Brown
situation with him, leaving the
field. I mean, it has been
everywhere. It's
been talked about, you know,
within Sports outside of
sports. It's just become a mega
story at this point. How did
you view this one? Especially we
haven't 24 hours to think
about what we saw.
Well, I'm kind of like everyone
else. I thought at first,
the first, an issue, the initial
thought was, he's very selfish.
He's doing this on his own. But
then I started thinking
I started thinking like, well,
something's really wrong with
this guy for him to get that
upset at that moment to to
express himself in that manner.
Like he's worked so hard to get
to this point where
he's trying to get the trust and
respect of his teammates
and his coaches and then
something like that happens
man, and it's just
It's really sad because all this
stuff started, you know,
years ago
when he was in Pittsburgh
and they allow them. We've heard
the stories Jack we've
heard the stories about him
missing meetings being late to
meeting. So in a sense, they
enabled him and then all of
a sudden you give him 40, 50
million bucks. Now, he becomes
a different player,
a person, but to me, a lot of
this steel and I'm not I'm not
saying that this is an excuse,
but I think that I think he
suffers from CTE. I think he's
definitely got some symptoms.
He's Snappy.
He's mood swings and you look at
the
you look at this head from
vantes. Burfict. You look at
this hit
and he was completely out. I've
never I play 15 years in
the league. I was never
completely out like that. He's
completely
out. That is a concussion. That
is something that's going to
stick with you for the rest of
your life. So when you talk
about,
you know, inconsistent Behavior
mood swings you, imagine your
son or somebody, you know,
getting hit like this,
this has permanent damage to it
and
And, you know, I would want to
leak to come in and I'm not
blaming the league at all. But I
would like to put a lead to
come in and really help this guy
because what they witness
and what we witness on Sunday
was,
you know, mental illness. It was
CTE. It was him making
a bad decision. It was all those
different things. And when
you're suffering from CT, and I
got many, many friends that
suffer from CT. We all suffer
from CTU. Play football, for
an extended period of time.
You've got hit
in the head, you suffer from
CTE, that was clearly something
that just made him. Nap and I
promise you at this point in
time. He's sitting at home and
he's not happy. He's not happy
about walking off the field
quit. And he's probably saying
like, oh my god. What the heck
did I do? And that's what
happens when you have CT, you
make decisions, you do things
and you all you sit back and
say,
why did I do something like
that?
Yeah, wow, they give people some
sense of how life changes
after multiple concussions, you
know, because some people never
played football at that level
and
it really can't relate to what
you're saying.
Well, I mean just think about I
mean, I like I said, I've lost
my mentor and one of my
brothers. Junior say I'll to
this.
Okay,
he shot himself. He committed
suicide. So
It's tough, you know, because
guys, go through a lot, you
know, they go through the
pressures of their families,
you know, asking for money and
trying to do the right thing.
And,
you know, you want to do the
right thing. You want to get
up, you want to go work out. You
want to be positive, but
yet that CTS got you in a
depressive State. It's got you
saying, no, you can't do that.
You can't be positive.
You have to be mean to your
kids. You have to snap on your
kids.
That's what CTE does and I've
set down. I've talked to 50
players at least 50 players and
they tell
We all the different types of
stories and we you know, we
have conversations about trying
to how do you deal with it? How
do you deal with this? You know,
but Antonio Brown, he
needs some spiritual guidance.
He needs medical attention. He
just needs people to come in
because a lot of times you have
people within your
circle and they're afraid to say
anything because they don't
want to get cut off. If someone
stands up and said you should
go and get help,
man. What make it out, my
circle, you out of here. You
you know, no longer part. So a
lot of people within those
circles. Are afraid to say
something because they feel
like they're going to
get, you know, basically kicked
out of the group.
It's tough Jack. It's just very
tough. Very, very emotional.
It's very tell if it's very true
what you're saying and I,
you know, I've known people who
have been in a b Circle and
they don't last long. I mean,
he's got a sort of a revolving
door of people around them and
it very quickly rotates and one
of the things that Tom Brady
said, right after his
compassion, right? So I think
it's important. Let's hear from
his
quarterback and somebody who
continually wanted to give him
another chance in the NFL. So
here was Tom Brady on his
podcast, talking about Antonio
Brown this from today.
It was just a very difficult
situation for everybody
involved. I've known Antonio for
a couple years now, you
know, pretty closely. And,
you know, we've obviously been
teammates and
I would just say I love him, I
care about him
and I have a lot of compassion.
I have a lot of empathy for
the things that
are happening in his life. So
it's a lot of challenges we all
face from time to time. Think
the best thing is to have
a support system, even outside
of football because
again, yeah, we are football
players.
As we're athletes.
We give everything we can on the
field, but we also have
off-field life's too and and I'm
going to continue to do
everything. I can to try to,
you know, be a great friend and
supportive to antonioni thinks
he's going through.
I have a lot of respect for Tom
Brady. And do you think about
Tom Brady, the love that he has
for Antonio Brown. Like Tom
Brady is a very busy guy. He's
got family wife kids. He's got
businesses. He's trying
to play football workouts. Yet.
This guy has taken Antonio
Brown and he has shown them to T
be 12, and he's mentored him.
He's been around his family. Ate
dinner with his wife and
kids.
I'm sure all that time. Tom
Brady loves this guy. He knows
that he needs help, and that's
what he needs. He needs more
guys, more positive people
around them because what I saw
on Sunday, man, it scared me
because you don't know what's
next. You don't know if he goes
and and something else
happened. You don't know
their stories that we hear about
all the time and I'm just
concerned for the brother man,
because he's not a bad guy.
He's just, he's just going
through a lot mentally.
Now, hear you? Cause we've seen
so many situations where bad
can get worse and we just hope
he gets help right now when
they're still maybe even
potentially some football ahead
of him. Who knows? But most
important thing is getting his
life in check
away from the field. So let's
get to number two on your
takeaways Rob, which is the NFC
and it's going through Lambeau
Field. We were just up there at
Lambeau Field. The icy
conditions. Tom
Tom, Brady, shooter looked like
Tom Brady, Aaron Rodgers way.
He's throwing the ball around
Davante, Adams, that connection
They have MVP back-to-back
years. It looks like something
special there in Green Bay right
now.
Yeah, I mean the number one seed
is huge for these guys
because obviously are Rogers,
he's dealing with a toe issue
but they also have three veteran
players that's coming
back
in the most important positions
outside of quarterback, you
know, Baca Tre left tackle Zaire
cornerback. And of course
we pass. Rusher was the Darius
Smith.
It's a
they have depth,
the defense has improved. Kenny
Clark is back in the middle.
I like the Green Bay Packers
man. I Will you talk about what
AJ
Dillon told us
remember a J dilla? He said,
hey, man, we love playing in
this weather because we know
when they come into this,
whether they feel this, whether
they feel the cold, they feel
the physicality and that's
exactly what Matt. Le
Flore did had a lot of in the
first half. There was a lot of
Aaron Jones, but in that third
and fourth quarter, he put a J
dilla. 245-pound bruising back
in their
War Minnesota now, and that's
what they plan on doing.
Let me tell you something.
I played at I played in
Foxborough.
And coming to Lambeau Field is
about 20 degrees colder. In
Foxborough that is going to be a
very difficult place to play,
especially if you're Dallas and
I still believe that Dallas is
capable of going in there,
and if they're playing on their
level,
they can beat the Green Bay
Packers,
but it's got to be a special day
because it's cold out there
brother and it affects
everybody.
It is and you really saw
firsthand up close and
personal. Why that a.j., Dylan,
pick is so important. It's for
these moments, right? It's a
week. 17 week, 18,
the playoff run,
Super Bowl going through Lambo.
This is what it was all about.
I thought it was really
interesting. When we asked
them. I want to run this clip
real quick about Aaron Jones,
AJ Dillon on the field at the
same time something we've
talked a lot about
here, was the answer. This was
very telling, I thought let's
run this.
We keep saying is we don't like
together more.
To coach about a I can't be
giving you all the secrets,
some
more games ahead of us. You just
got waiting.
Hey, you know a Jack that's
exactly what they're going to
do in the playoffs. They're
saving it right there. Same. As
soon as he said. Hey, I can't
give you all the secrets. We
already knew exactly what he was
talking about.
You got about halfway through
your question and I saw just
the look on his face. Just that
little smile come across
the space and we already saw a
couple of plays in the game
where they were both in their
collectively,
but there's so much creativity
that you're able to do when you
got Jones at his wide receiver.
Basically gets to play that
slot receiver. You can run a
full route, tree and two
rounds, and all those
possibilities.
And then the power running game,
right off it, they're
starting to tease it into the
lineup, but that as just
a second layer, to the power
running game. Dylan is bringing
this Packers offense can beat
you in a lot of ways. They need
to think about the way, they're
playing defense on top of it.
I don't see a team in the NFC
right now, especially watching
the Cowboys, get beat Yesterday
by the Cardinals, in the way
that they did. I just don't see
a team in the NFC right now
that I would believe strongly
could go in there and beat
the Packers at Lambeau. I just
don't feel confidently. And
anybody to be honest,
the only concern I have and I
want you to see if you and we
haven't you and I have not
talked about this. The only
concern I have Have with the
Packers offense, ively
is, do they depend on Davante
Adams, too much? Because
it just seems like everything is
about Davante, Adams,
every single thing. And if it's
a hamstring or twisted, ankle,
or something like that. Will
they have enough with those
others? That's what's important.
This is wonderful.
This is one of the, the
is a double coverage and he
still forced it.
He still forcing it down a
field. I know Davante. Adams is
the man, he's great. But if you
Get a really good team in here
with a great defense and they
double-team him with their best
safety and it best corner and
they take him out the game.
Do you believe that MDS? Do you
believe that Allen Lazard? Do
you believe that they have
enough in the passing game? And
maybe they make
Aaron Jones, a wide receiver in
the slot. Do you feel like they
have enough in the passing game.
If something were to
happen to Davante Adams that
they can still win football
games because it seems like they
depend on them too much.
Yeah, well they definitely do in
the crazy thing. Is they
have a remarkable record when
he's out of the lineup of still
being able to win. It's like
four no five and do something
like that when he's out and you
don't really care. Explain how
but it's just that Aaron Rodgers
can overcome those type
of things. And
yeah, I'm with you man and
watching them practice. I got
to go up to one of their
training camps. One time.
I watch them practice and the
timing that they have and
the way that they're able to
communicate to me. They're like
two brothers that have played
backyard football
together for their entire
childhoods. That they know what
the other guys think in. They
even know what they're
thinking, and they're able to
adjust and do certain things on
the fly. But when you watch them
practice
Rod, it's a lot of Aaron
by himself, throw into buckets.
That's what he does. I mean, he
is just trying to hit a spot.
He's just trying to hit a spot
and he'll do it. A hundred times
in a row in the Crowd
Goes Nuts when he does it
and then when you watch Davante
Adams practice, it's like dance
steps. He's taking, you know,
nine steps and he said that
spot nine steps and he said that
spot and he's patient.
It's right there and they just
hit that exact spot. But to
watch those two just do.
It time and time again. And if
you over play it, okay, there
it is on the back shoulder. I
just don't see any wide
receiver quarterback Duo. That
are on the same identical page.
Like, I see with these two guys
right now and it's why they're
at the top of the NFC. And at
the top of the NFL.
Yeah, we look at the numbers. We
see all the production on
Sunday, but we don't really pay
it. We can't see the all
the work that's done. Behind the
scenes. All the tape, all the
conversations walking past each
other and you know, in
the hallway and just all the
walkthroughs that they go
through out on the field. So in
order
for them to have that chemistry
and that continuity, you have
to put a lot of work in is
obvious that they've been doing
that.
Yeah, and listen are Rogers play
with some unbelievable
talent for him to say that this
is the best player that he's
ever played with that goes a
long way in my mind's eye. So
let's get you to your third
takeaway, which is
the Cincinnati Bengals, and they
have clinched the AFC
North first time. Since 2015,
big win over the Kansas City
Chiefs. How did you see that
one?
You remember when Joe burrow, he
said, he wasn't,
he wasn't apologizing for
passing in the fourth quarter
or something like that against a
Ravens. That's I really knew
that's like man. I'm not
apologizing for that. I'll keep
doing it. The game's not over.
That's when I knew his mindset
was different like
just just that gangster in him.
You know, I'm saying, like Joe
burrow is, he's that dude, man.
And when he shows up, he raises
everybody's level and they trust
them. They believe them.
They, it doesn't matter. If
there are two
scores down, they trust and
believe them. He does a great
job of spreading the wealth.
It's not just Jamar Chase.
Yeah, he gets all the attention
but is void is T Higgins.
You no, Joe Mixon out of the
backfield. The offensive line
has improved. These guys are
playing with a lot of heart. A
lot of toughness
and for them to upset,
the Kansas City Chiefs. This is
not a mistake.
This is something they believe
that they can do
and this is one of the best
teams
in the AFC. We got to start
really giving them credit and
just thinking that this is
Lucknow. This is skilled. These
guys have worked extremely hard
to get to this point and Joe
burrow, is that dude?
When I agree, I mean, just just
the way that he dismantled
Wink. Martindale is defense has
all those different Blitz.
Looks that he brings then come
back a week later into out dual
Patrick Mahomes on a day where
Patrick Mahomes is on fire.
You just don't see other
quarterbacks do that in
the belief in the trust that all
his teammates have NM and I was
thinking this on the car ride
over here, Rod know we hear
these comparisons to a young Tom
Brady.
Nobody would know a young, Tom
Brady better than you.
So how do you hear those
comparisons? Is there something
to that? What do you think?
He was better than Tom Brady, as
a young to I mean, think
about it. I mean, Joe burrow
right. Now, I believe was
better than Tom Brady, when Tom
Brady was in his second or when
he was really young.
Yeah, man, I do got unbe has
unbelievable arm Talent. He's
got a swag and a confidence,
like he's coming out of college
with this
with this are with this huge. I
mean, he's a very humble, dude.
I like them.
So, not in a negative way, but
he has this level of confidence
in himself. And when used, when
you see him talk, when you see
him, interviewing, when you Him
interacting with his teammates.
He's been a leader,
they believe in him, they trust
them
and and I don't believe Tom
Brady was as good as Joe Bro,
right now at this point in time.
And that's saying something
right there man. I look at
these weapons to I look at Jamar
Chase. I mean that that
first touchdown he caught where
he says, he's a little 15 yard
and an and there's six Defenders
around and I went
back and I count. I mean there's
there is 62 fenders, that are
perfectly positioned to make
look right here.
This one's downside of this was
a second or third touchdown.
There's six Defenders around.
There's so many touchdowns you
get them mixed up in everybody.
It was one cut. Is it right
here? What's the right here?
And he blazes all of them with
it? Is Rod. It's like you see
Tyree kill do that on the other
sideline, but he is in rarefied
air with how fast he looks on an
NFL field. That's hard to
do, man.
And not many teams have an
outstanding, a superstar like
him, because just think about
him. He's Odell Beckham.
He's like a 2022 version of
Odell. Becker. He's bigger
faster, and stronger old Dale.
He's a lot. He just as talented
as when, you know, Odell Beckham
came out, but think
about this. This is the thing. I
was reading about
jobber. Errol buying his
offensive linemen, a bunch of
Iced Out watches. Did you hear
about that?
Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah.
Yep. Okay. So it reminds me of
Tom Brady, when I
got to the New England Patriots.
He bought all his offense of
lineman
Audi's SUVs, and I'm like, you
know what? That's, that's
pretty, you know,
it takes a pretty special
quarterback to really show
that appreciation to their
offensive line. Because a lot
of quarterbacks have said, may
you all get paid millions of
dollars that you have to do your
job, but for these guys to
show appreciation,
you know, and by their
Lyman things and just showing
that that gratitude man. That
was big. It just shows his
maturity to
And that offensive line has
gotten way better. I mean, they
were bad last year. You should
have some of the hits that he
was taken last year. Jobber. I
mean one of them that it could
have could have well ended his
career and that the fact
that he's been able to come back
from that be on time to
play week, one, even though
everybody was going, you know,
Joe, let's take an extra month
here, man, you know, we need
you for 15 years. We don't need
you for this and he's like,
no, I'm playing week one like
we're doing something this year
and that's what they did. I
mean, it's, it's just been
amazing to watch him lead in
this way. It's amazing. Almost
in the way that watching Tom. To
go down to
Tampa his first year and put
together a championship team.
Like
some guys have the ability to
just make those around them
better and believe and all of a
sudden there's confidence and
I think you hit it right on the
head. There's a calm cool
confidence about him and it's
not cocky.
It's just a confidence. And I
just think that these receivers
these lineman the defense, even
the head coach and Zach Taylor
use coach to to win team last
year.
They just believe that they can
win every game and by golly.
They're starting to win these
games where They're playing
the Kansas City Chiefs, the best
team in the NFL in some ways.
And what people don't realize
too is, you know, it's not like
Zach Taylor has done a really
good job of allowing these
young men and it's locker room
to be themselves to show their
personality.
A lot of young coaches will try
to control and I don't
celebrate, don't do that, don't
know, smoking cigars on
Instagram and celebrate. He's
allowing these guys to openly
Show The World. Hey, that we're
confident. We believe a where
the Cincinnati Bengals were
coming for you.
We going to celebrate this
division title. But hey, we're
trying to go to the Super Bowl
and this is what this is
the Mindset of the Cincinnati
Bengals, but it comes from Joe
burrow. It comes from their head
coach and I'm just,
it's really nice to see these
guys able to have their own
personalities and be who they
are and just and have fun
playing football.
And I think the magic to of Zack
Taylor, that's a big one
is that he listens to Joe burrow
and not only within
the offense of Joe. What do you
want to run? Okay, let's go do
that to listen to a Young
quarterback like that,
but he he stuck his neck out for
Jamar Chase like he wanted
to be teammates again. Which
Amar Chase and they were In
a soul, there was great options
that they could have taken
their. But he kept saying, man,
you think just to Jefferson's
great
up there in Minnesota. I played
with both of these guys
Jamar, Chase is the better
player and how is it played out
in the very first year? He goes
and he breaks all of Justin
Jefferson's records right here
with Joe burrow is as
quarterback. So, when you have
somebody like him, when you
have a mind like him,
the best thing you can do is
listen, and I'll tell you what
Rod. You should hear. Joe
burrow, talk about Zack Taylor.
He couldn't give a higher. You
of his head coach. And I think
that's why it's because he's
listening to him.
And guess who's the coach of the
year? I know everybody's
talking about Mike, Vrabel. It's
not my Grable and he's
that's my former. Teammate. He's
done a wonderful job with
the Tennessee Titans with that.
Number one seed. It's Zack
Taylor
what he's been able to do. He's
come in. He's changed
the culture, you know, Matt Le
Flore to. But at the end of
the day, you got Aaron Rodgers,
you don't have a
Young quarterback coming off an
ACL injury, and a lot of
questions about your offensive
line. Questions about your
defense. Zach Taylor is
the coach of the year.
He's done a phenomenal job. This
bingos team. Like we
didn't think this bangle T. Like
we tune in for
the Bengals. You know, I'm
saying? We're not missing that
big game
for nothing in the world Jack.
It's must-see TV, Jamar
chaseborough. Those guys are
office. Joe Mixon is balling,
man. I like the mango Smith.
I know it's a fun and they
transcend a small market. Like
it's a Cincinnati team. Its
small market and like they
shouldn't be this national team,
but the star power
transcends that and people just
want to watch
some people want to watch some
RJ's.
People want to watch Joe people
want to watch mix in it and
I defense the way that they've
built it through free agency.
Pretty cool to. That's a good
good time to transition, though
to have let your for take away
the Titans
after the Bengals, beat the
Kansas City Chiefs. The Titans
Now Elevate to that one seed,
and all of a sudden even
without King Henry, your former.
Teammate has them right
back at the top of the AFC.
We were out in l.a.
When they played the Rams
and what happened, they got
there. They just flat-out kick
the Rams but because Mike Vrabel
and this is something
that he took from Bill
Belichick. He preaches
physicality
dominating the line of scrimmage
and that's what they've done
Jeffrey, Simmons,
Jones, Landry, the Nico all
tree, all those guys.
That's what they do. They get
after the quarterback. They
stop the run. They play physical
football. They don't
make a lot of mistakes. They
wait for the opposing team to
make the mistakes
and variable. He gets a lot of
respect in that locker room
because he treats his players.
Well, he's honest with them.
It's no BS. He has empathy
toward him. Get? Why? Because
he was a great player. He played
in the league for a long
time.
And the cool thing about
variable is
no matter how much success you
have. He's going to
he's going to constantly
challenge you. He's going to
constantly push you. That's what
he does. And he's done
a great job this year.
Right. I mean, just just the
ability to not panic after
Henry left the lineup that that
was the amazing thing to me and
those receivers have been banged
up and and out of it,
but they won with their physical
offensive line. That's
just moving people even Deonte
Foreman. I mean, he went for 132
and a touchdown yesterday.
So it's not all about King
Henry's about that offensive
line. Look, look at that push
right there. He's not getting
touched at least 10 yards, down
the field and that's part of
what this team has
been. And then you think about
King Henry if they get this
first round by that he would,
Actually be able to return for
the divisional round
healthy fresh. After all. These
other players have played
an 18-week NFL season. I'm he
almost had a thousand yards
only play in about 10 or 12
games. Whatever he ended up
with. Excellent point comes
back,
man, that could be tough team to
play.
Hey Jack, that was an excellent
point. And the thing about it
is when he comes back. He
doesn't have to be thrust into
action where he has to carry the
ball, 25 or 30 times. He
can come in. You can get them 10
to 12 carries just to get
them back. Acclimated. You still
have Deonte for man
who's done a wonderful job, and
now you have that one-two.
Punch, not just this year, but
moving forward.
What do you what do you think
just from a personality
standpoint? Why do the players?
Love our seem to love variable
so much. It just seems like
they're always all over his
back after a win. Like they
can't wait to celebrate with
them.
What is it that everybody's so
drawn to just about his
personality.
He's okay mean he's a really
good person. You know, he's
a really good person who's easy
to talk to. Like I said,
I said, he's empathetic. So he
has empathy toward others. He's
played in the league
and he played at a very high
level. One a bunch of Super
Bowl so he knows exactly what
the players are going through.
And even in one clip after he
won on Sunday. He's like, hey
guys, I'll see you on Wednesday.
So he knows what it takes given
these guys rest. He understands
the pulse of his locker room,
you know, he's not looking at
some some sheets and says, well,
maybe I should do this.
He
He can feel the temperature of
his locker room. So when those
guys come to him and say Coach,
man, we're a little tired. Can
we take a day off or make? Can
we make it more of a mental
day?
He knows how to adjust. He just
a great Coach man, and he loves
what he does
and makes sense why they've had
so much success. So let's get
to the Cardinals and the Cowboys
couple teams at the top
of the NFC got together. The
Cowboys are coming off that
Sunday night win over
Washington, where they just
blew him all the way. I
don't see blowouts. Like that
very often in the NFL, but they,
Handled them. It's been a hot
football, team offense,
starting to look like they were
back in form. But then Arizona
goes into Dallas and gets the
win. How they do it.
Well, I mean you think about
Arizona you lose your best
receiver and you know DeAndre
Hopkins,
you lose three straight
and you even lose to Detroit. So
now you start to question
yourself. Are we really that
good? Can we compete against
these guys that you have to go
on the road and you beat
the Dallas Cowboys? That was a
huge
win for them going into the
playoffs because they know now.
Hey guys, when we're focused,
when we're together, when we're
holding, we can play against
anybody, but the problem is,
sometimes they play down to the
Their competition, and they
come in, they take things for
granted. But when this team is
focused,
but when this team is focused
and they don't come Focus every
single day.
They play extremely hard and
column Marie. I mean it's going
to come down to calamari. This
is a good defense, but it comes
down to his decision-making it
comes to him. Not making
those turnovers and him planned
and just doing special things.
They no longer have the on tree
Hopkins. So they have to deal
with guys like Cristian Kirk AJ
Green, they're going to have to
make plays chess.
Chase Edmunds, he's back a
little healthier in the Run
game. So
Arizona Cardinals are there. I'm
not too sure. They'll be
excited about going to Green Bay
at the had to go to Green
Bay and playing that weather.
But um,
you know, a lot of props to
them, being a very good Dallas,
Cowboy team,
And they did play Green Bay
really tough earlier in
the year. That was a Thursday
night. Game is actually
the game were Kyler got heard.
They took him deep into the
fourth
quarter and that game ended up
losing, Kyler ended up. Missing
a couple of games.
Handful of games, after that,
when they just arrested him up
with Colt, McCoy came in and
played a little bit for him.
But at least, you know, you can
hang with them and I thought
would happen in this game. One
was AJ Green who was
a veteran wide receiver. Going
up against Ray Vaughan, digs
who we know? Well, he's
aggressive and he's you
double-digit interception guy.
But you have to live with the
risk to and he just kept
getting double moved by a
veteran receiver in AJ Green,
and it's a big reason why they
lost this game because he's
a vet. He knows that you're
going to be aggressive. He's
watched
tape. He knows you're gonna jump
on stuff like that. And so
he kept hitting them with these
double moves. And Trayvon Biggs
just didn't have the answer. AJ
Green had a huge Day stepping
up.
No doubt, but defensively, I
look at them from the defensive
side. They have to just continue
to play hard and
complement the offense. Isaiah
Simmons has planned out of his
mind. He really looks
comfortable out there.
He seems like he's really
starting to pick up the NFL
game Buddha Baker. They got to
get a really good. Secondary to
got some pass rushers in
Chandler Jones,
who knows? Man? The Arizona
Cardinals, they have
the talent, but do they have the
mindset?
I'll tell you what. Else was
interesting to with Kyler is
that The Cowboys have some
amazing pass rushers and we
were just there, we saw him in
persons, Micah Parsons and
Lawrence and Randy Gregory.
I mean they are amazing and they
are huge athletes.
But what they couldn't really do
was get their hands on this
punt returner back there. I
mean, Kyler Murray is not your
average, 62 63 quarterback who
stands in there. And is that
that specific spot? I mean this
dude is quick and he is just
like
a little lightning bug back
there. And how many times you
see these? Six six guys get
there and they had them just
like they have so Many
quarterbacks
and before you know, it, he's 10
15 yards down the field.
I mean, even on that final
drive. When it got to be a
three-point
game, they ran two. Quarterback
runs four first downs and they
ran an option. They ran to
quarterback options, where you
pitched it for two more. First
downs, go run out the clock.
It's just not something. Dan
Quinn that Cowboys defense are
used to seeing nobody's used to
seeing a quarterback back
there. Playing like a punt
return. He just got them
a couple times and I think it's
why they won that game.
And and really a great job by
them really limiting what
the impact of Michael Parsons,
you know, like we've seen him
take
over and just completely
dominate games
and they did it. I think he had
15 tackles maybe, no sax, no
pass defense, anything like
that. So they did an excellent
job, you know, taking him away.